what's this about today
so i wanted to talk about a paper just
come out it's entitled gravitational
wave constraints on the equatorial
ellipticity of millisecond pulsars the
front page of it as well as the title is
basically all authors
and in fact if i turn to the second page
that's all authors too and if i turn to
the third page
that's all authors
wow the reason why it's so many authors
is because it's one of the papers from
ligo and virgo so the gravitational wave
detection consortium and actually this
is about not detecting gravitational
waves and it turns out sometimes not
detecting gravitational waves is as
interesting as detecting them they're
looking at neutron stars pulsars so
these are these very compact stellar
remnants where the whole mass of a star
up to a couple of solar masses is
pressed down into a region about 20
kilometers across so tiny little objects
that are left over when stars blow up a
supernova professor is there a
difference between a neutron star and a
pulsar are all neutron stars also a
pulsar
so all pulsars are neutron stars but not
all neutron stars are pulsars so pulsars
are the ones we can see and the reason
why we can see them is because these
objects are rotating generally quite
fast they have a magnetic field if that
magnetic field is sort of misaligned
with the rotation then you get basically
a lighthouse effect you have the light
that's being produced along the magnetic
field lines through a process called
synchrotron and as the thing spins
around you basically see the flashes of
light as it goes past and so that's how
they were first detected by jocelyn bell
burnell where she detected these very
regular pulses which are from these
flashes of light as the neutron stars
rotating if it turns out that the
lighthouse beam happens not to be
pointed in our direction then we won't
see it and so basically there'll still
be a neutron star but we won't see it as
a pulsar but anyway some of them are
pulsars and they're spinning some of
them very fast some of them a thousand
times a second the things called
millisecond pole source i mean they are
mind-blowing things right you've got
several times the mass of the sun
squashed down into a region 20
kilometers across rotating up to a
thousand times a second quite phenomenal
objects but one consequence of that is
that you might expect them to radiate
gravitational waves now if they're
exactly symmetrical they won't because
if you think about it if you had
something which is actually just kind of
completely say it was spherical or even
it was somewhat flattened if it's not
actually
sort of if it's just rotating around
that axis then the shape doesn't change
at all in the in three dimensions it
just kind of rotates around which means
that the gravitational field the thing
is producing really doesn't change
either whereas if it were kind of very
lopsided as it rotated around the shape
would kind of change in the sky which
means its gravitational field would
change and one of the consequences of
that is that it would then radiate
gravitational waves you can calculate
well how much by where gravitational
waves would it radiate the answer is not
a huge amount it's nothing like the
things that they've been detecting with
ligo like you know these merging neutron
stars and black holes and things which
produce these enormous bursts of
gravitational waves you might think well
you know they can only just detect these
much more spectacular events how could
they hope to detect one of these neutron
stars the answer is they know where to
look because we know exactly what the
period of rotation of these things are
because if it's a pulsar we just measure
the time between the pulses and so for
example the crab pulsar goes round 30
times a second 30 hertz and from that
and turns out the gravitational waves
are radiated at twice the frequency of
the rotation period so inconveniently it
would actually be 60 hertz which is the
electricity frequency of a fair part of
the world which turns out to be a major
source of interference so you can't
actually detect it or it's very hard to
detect the crab pulsar but other pulsars
have less inconvenient frequencies that
they're rotating at so then you know
exactly what frequency you look at you
can just kind of add up all the data and
just search at that one frequency to say
is there anything going on if i combine
all the data together at that one
frequency it's a little bit more
complicated because it could be for
example if the thing really were
slightly lopsided it might be kind of
processing around as well as rotating
which changed the frequency a little bit
it could be that the interior of the
neutron star is actually rotating at a
slightly different speed from the
exterior it could be kind of sloshing
around faster in the interior which
again would change the frequency a bit
so you have to search around a little
bit in frequency but you know pretty
much exactly where to look so they
looked in all these places they've now
got lots of data from ligo from virgo
that they were able to look to see if
there are any emissions from these
neutron stars the answer is there isn't
any they were able to put really strong
upper limits on how much gravitational
waves there are and hence indirectly
that tells you how asymmetric the pulsar
is allowed to be and the answer is
absolutely tiny right it turns out if
you wanted to make a pulsar lopsided
if you made it lopsided so supposing you
had an exactly spherical neutron star 20
kilometers across
if you distorted one side of it
literally by a hair's breadth so by the
width of a human hair
that would create enough asymmetry that
with the sensitivity they had they'd
have been able to detect it
so they know to within a hair's breath
these neutron stars have to be exactly
symmetric
so professor i presume they looked at a
few neutron stars not just one there's
about half a dozen maybe in this one the
thing i was thinking when you first
started telling me about this was surely
something spinning that fast i would
have thought maybe there would be
something about that process that would
make it symmetrical and the fact that
all of them are symmetrical i mean is it
a cause or an effect i guess is what i'm
saying
it's got i mean i think even if they
weren't spinning they'd still end up
very symmetrical because the pull of the
i mean they're basically held together
by nuclear forces right and those forces
are so strong that they will actually
pull everything in in a very symmetric
fashion but being able to measure it you
know to within a hair's breath for a
pulsar it really shows quite how
amazingly symmetric they really are
another way of saying this is that they
would have a very smooth surface or yeah
absolutely and you know smoother than
the proverbial baby's bottom they really
are it has to be absolutely smooth
because any little ripples there were
would create those kind of asymmetries
that they'd be able to detect in
gravitational waves smoother than a
billiard ball
way way way smoother than a billion
can we make things that smooth is this
smoother than humans can make or you
know you hear things about these you
know these spheres of silicon and stuff
like that and
that's a very good question i honestly
don't know i'd have to do the
calculations to say yeah i mean when one
of the things when they were thinking
about redefining the kilogram was about
making incredibly smooth spheres of
silicon to within kind of a single atom
and i'd have to do the calculation to
figure out whether or not this is
smoother than that but it i wouldn't be
surprised if it was because it you know
here we're talking about 20 kilometers
across and a hair's breadth
so it really is a tiny perturbation what
are we talking about when we say smooth
for something that's not really matter
though is it we say oh smoother than a
billiard bowl but it's this isn't made
of matter as we know it is it or
it kind of is i mean it's made of
neutrons mostly at least it's out what
is this stuff what is it
i know i know there would be a lot of
problems if i went close to a neutron
star and tried to touch it i'm not naive
to that but if i did touch it what am i
touching is it is it hard is it cold is
it hot like what does it compare to just
above the the surface of the neutron
star is its atmosphere which again is
tiny but there are you know energetic
electrons and so on in the immediate
vicinity of it so you'll probably be
able to touch those but i honestly don't
know is this your answer um but apart
from the fact that i wouldn't recommend
it but beyond that i really don't know
how what you would actually feel if you
were able to stroke a neutron star
i'll put that on my backup list
[Laughter]
i guess there is one other thing to say
about it which is that there was already
a constraint on how smooth these things
were which comes from the fact that if
they were somewhat asymmetric and they
were giving out these gravitational
waves that energy has to come from
somewhere and the answer is it comes
from the spin of the neutron star and so
what you would expect is that if it were
radiating these gravitational waves away
through these kind of asymmetries the
neutron star should do what's known as
spinning down it should slow down but
that comes back to probably to
the the pulsar effect again remember i
said that if there's a magnetic field
which is a bit misaligned with the
rotation you'll see these pulses one of
the other things of having the magnetic
field kind of spinning around like that
is that in itself produces
electromagnetic waves which also carry
away energy so some of the energy being
carried away from a neutron star causing
it to spin down comes from this what's
called magnetic dipole radiation the
fact that you've got this spinning
magnet the most conservative thing you
can say is well let's presume pretend
that that's not there at all maybe if
the entire spin down were just coming
from gravitational waves what would that
mean for the asymmetry of the neutron
star
and it turns out that already gives you
a quite interesting limit on how smooth
a neutron star has to be what's new
about this result is this is the first
time they've gone beyond that limit to
actually measure effectively a limit on
the gravitational waves themselves
rather than from this in indirect effect
tell you what black holes get all the
good publicity and the glamour but i
think neutron stars are awesome you know
at least they can do stuff right a black
hole is just black and there's not much
you can say about it interesting things
go on around it but neutron stars you
can actually say interesting things
about the neutron star itself
so 140 i mean is is out here they found
a bump they found an increase in the
number
of uh
electron positron pairs coming out to
have a melting temperature of about 25
000 kelvin which is kind of the typical
temperature of a lightning bolt and the
specific heat capacity of water